[Music]
oh didn't see you there aren't you
supposed to be leaving presents no
you're thinking of my brother Santa I'm
takings Clause takings Clause with an E
you don't know your Constitution do you
I learned about it in school public
school it gives us our rights yeah
that's public school look Constitution
doesn't give you rights it protects the
rights you have from the government but
it's not doing a great job so I got to
take your stuff my stuff Fifth Amendment
right there read it nor shall private
property be taken for public use without
just compensation
boom what's just compensation I already
gave it to you this is just a pocket
Constitution it's not just a
constitution it's just
compensation this is yeah a
little
bit aren't you going to compensate me
for that no I didn't take that I broke
it but you broke it you buy it yeah well
we'll find out soon enough diler versus
Texas Supreme Court the what Texas Texas
basically built a concrete Dam alongside
Route 10 to keep the road dry but the
other side of the road was somebody's
Ranch so when it rained a lot the ranch
turned into a lake and a bunch of cows
and horses died and you know that's
awful yeah yeah yeah real sad but the
point is they didn't mean for that to
happen it just happened so tough luck
then I'll sue you yeah no I have
qualified immunity cuz I'm acting in an
official capacity where's new process
clause or equal protection Clause aren't
you a little old believe in those huh
this is the worst time of year I mean
election season's right around the
corner
[Music]